so then
here's my chat
what because you're not live
um pull up your phone it should get a
notification got it
a notification oh so today
maybe that was just up there from when
we unplugged the internet
maybe what's up guys
can we hear yes we can hear
what's up
that monkey i saw what's up
hello hello i have friends today
this is ally cat and this is suma
what's good host of cosmic culture
and just a person alex family cat no
just a person that's famous herself
for her yeah twitch streamer youtuber
does it all
yeah that's me
who's ready for episode three i should
mute this i'm sorry
how is the audio i think it's good hello
to everybody who is from india hello
love back to india hello
[Laughter]
hello what's up chris original hi girl
batman what's up girl
hello everybody i did shave yeah hey
noah thanks for the a i super appreciate
that noah g
thanks for the no nation thanks so much
for supporting the channel you're
awesome
super appreciate that thank you what
time did it start for me
it hasn't started yet it should start in
14
minutes and just so everybody knows i
can't show the whole thing but i will
throughout us watching it show a clip
here and there
but obviously i can't stream the whole
thing because i would get
copyrighted and striked and my channel
will get removed so that's not cool
and i need a i need to make videos
what's up everybody
how's it going we do love marvel we're
ready from the hey love back to india
how's it going
abraham manoj i'm an a-hole
hello everybody all right what do we got
here let's see
13 minutes it seems like everything's
working fine
we can hear and that's kind of all we
actually
need to hear we just kind of need to
hear that that's all we we kind of have
right now
um i can
one do got it set right there we're just
gonna put that back
let me just make sure everything's set
up got my timer for those of you who are
gonna
watch it with me
yep that'll be in the corner there we're
not starting yet don't let this fool you
there you go
all right well from nepal i'll stop that
reset that you did and we got it here
hall
egypt hey egypt dang girl say hi to me
love back from
love back to egypt hi that's awesome
that you're here watching
is that the hot girl you wanted to say
hi to you did i miss this hold on
is that new philippines is this new
sri lanka no okay
marvin maurice hello
thank you for joining all the way from
egypt
we are best friends woke walk totally
uh no it's coming out in
12 minutes not next week it's coming out
in 12 minutes episode three
uh yeah so for those of you who just
joined it seems like we have like 200
more followers
or joiners now this is chris rosser from
cosmic culture
alicat she streams on twitch she also
has youtube channel
as well we all live together
tony mr beach mursed hey wolves thanks
appreciate that blackberry disney plus
yeah it's just it's certainly looking
like that huh
they're probably gonna do the wonder
woman thing right put it on disney plus
and then put it on
in in the theaters at the same time hey
florida australia
we're all from florida we're not from
australia but we'd like to go there
alaska donna love from ghana
what up uh i have played marvel straight
of course
i haven't played it in a while hey
dallas i'm a huge dallas cowboys fan
fan mr b who's ready to be up all night
what's up daniel morgan love back to
ghana hey
uk wait
the agents of shield finale in the uk
are you just now
getting that what did i am i
misunderstanding that
is that is that really a thing was
super delayed what's up nehemiah
williams i'm sorry if i mispronounce
everybody's names
i'll do my best turkey
hey from all over the world yeah that's
crazy from all over
norway austria norway hey
we got a ton of i should have put sludge
out on
yeah can you not i can't now no no
whatever we're
imagining it who's ready grease 10
minutes ooh
grease awesome that's so freaky can you
get that hammer i have stormbreaker here
oh we haven't done that yet i haven't
unboxed it yet because i want to do a
video on it
but i have stormbreaker right there look
i'll grab it hold on
malaysia i'm waiting to unbox this thing
hold it chris i haven't uh i haven't
unboxed it yet present it like vanilla
so i will open this and uh do a do a
youtube video on this
i'll do a youtube video on this one
i played hockey like my whole life so
i've been to canada many times
hey it's tony g's tony and bit viper
from the alley cat stream thank you for
joining us
uh and mr migs hey we're popular india
thank you
that's awesome super appreciate that i
do watch
uh i watch channels like desi nerd and
uh
i can't remember the other one i watched
but i watched desi nerd i like that
indian channel
yeah i'm definitely gonna do unboxing uh
a video
for the for that for sure nine minutes
excuse me got our g fuel our energy
because we're going to be up all the
time
amsterdam hey
baby yoda in the back fact about
amsterdam i've spent a lot of time there
and it's breaking [ __ ] netherlands
and bait you mr hit it warren
drop the bars
hello hello luck [ __ ] i remember you
from
last stream thank you so much for that
new york city what's up
poland nice philippines
leave stormbreaker the girl will kill
thanos she'll get her
she'll get him what's your weapon of
choice okay hold on
season seven only came out in november
and disney plus in the uk
oh my gosh that's insane well hey i hope
you enjoyed it
stuff i hope you enjoyed it oh super
super yeah yeah yeah
yeah i watched that channel super super
and desi nerd are the other two ones
hey orlando that's where we're all from
we all moved uh here to utah from
orlando michigan i've been there
all right south africa nice
oh hey penguin you're back they're
making me want to travel
about that oh that's a predicament man
do you have your phone can you like
don't go watch it
his words but hey thank you so much for
the donation and uh i remember you from
last time you've done it a few times too
so thank you so much
um that's a predicament man i'm i i
uh chris chris has spoken is what else i
made your decision
hail hydra hail had iowa
she's kind of cute huh
yes we got a few more people guys this
is chris
from cosmic culture this is alicat
from her own twitch channel her youtube
channel they're all called alicat and we
all live together we're all roommates
uh chris also edits my videos for cosmic
wonder so many of you may know him from
that
um hey yeah canadian lad me and him are
uh buds we teamed up on some theories
not too long ago
he's a good dude his uh his his videos
are insane how he uh
watches them at 0.25 speed that's pretty
cool hey
what's up oh monstrous what's up my dude
how's it going
glad to see you in here jf what's up man
i see you there too what's up
hey way wavy d
productions who do you think is going to
be the first x-men
um me
[Laughter]
not her um
so when you say the first x-men i'm
going to take that as like the first
mutant in the mcu because i don't think
they'll be called x-men at first
um
i don't know who the first one's going
to be maybe storm i was going to say
storm my money's on
maybe storm i think that would be a good
one um
so maybe storm um but i'm not 100
sure about that there was some talks
that there was going to be
not not like shown but like a mention of
wolverine
in the falcon and the winter soldier
with like the weapon x program and stuff
like that especially with thunderbolt
ross
kind of probably being behind everything
so not
too sure about that but
i think they'll name drop a few before
we actually see a few i think storm has
a good
chance of appearing
there so much happening is the canadian
lad in the chat because a bunch of you
are talking like he
is and if he is what is up my dude
six minutes six minutes
winnipeg canada i've been there
oh well that's fun thank you
let's get married
[Laughter]
um i need to i don't know how to get in
here
what are you trying to do get into the
chat like type
monster what's going on hi bacon i don't
know how to do that because i can't uh
i can only delete messages from this
chat in here
oh what if i sign it to chat there you
go
let's do that all right we have five
minutes here we go
that's better so then i'm gonna go back
up
what's up hulk smash how's it going from
bangladesh
wait so when's the third episode coming
out today yeah it's coming out
today yeah
for my new toes and thank you so much
for that donation
oh i can't go up further in the chat oh
dang moss truck went to alley cat stream
that was too fast
[Laughter]
found the loophole
hello paul paul g says hello alicat
hello it comes out very very soon
very very very very very soon
four minutes still woof woof
i will say it at the end before
everybody gets off you don't want it
um let's do this
so i can look at both things here
uh hey mikey
i hope that's from parks and rec
otherwise i don't know where he's from
if not whatever oh wait hold on godzilla
versus kong trailer
sunday chris coming back to cosmic
culture
chris covers a lot of godzilla vs that's
all i've talked about the last week
there's big news coming with godzilla
someone asks where is felix dragon club
he's not up here because they're all
who's right hey that's somebody that's
somebody we know that's louise
probably louie
um nice b shirt from
rid duel mr beast gotta wrap the merch
uh we have three minutes three
[Music]
minutes
yeah evan peters i think he could be
mephisto
what's up i think it could be mephisto
although i heard a really weird rumor
lately that said they straight up um
got rid of aaron taylor johnson so
they're going to bring in
evan peters to play a different version
of quicksilver which i think would be
pretty confusing
it would be really confusing there's
some x-men fox x-men stuff right there
that would be really confusing i don't
i don't know how people would receive
that um
i i don't know uh i'm hoping he plays
mephisto
hey not gonna go to work meaning after
all i'm sure they'll understand this one
yes
[Applause]
that's what we all wanted to hear
they'll they should understand if
they're if they're good people they're
decent people they will understand
that's exciting one strike
what to say episode three intro will be
like the brady bunch the brady bunch
out jody hmm actually jody is not wrong
makes an extremely good point fantastic
thank you thank you for the dono
um very good point i think wanda and
petro are the first mutants yeah
i think they had the mutant genes and i
think it was activated by
the stones torture yeah well you know
the mine stone
uh okay let's get ready for this fan
because
it's about to start i need to be able to
access this
that's fine mine's not up yet
it's not 12 yet
oh yeah it's not one yet
all right guys woof woof i'm worth it
thank you
ali kat would make a great marvel
character oh thank you what marvel
character would you be
that's so hard i don't know wanna
yeah i could wear a black suit with ears
black suits she should be alley cat
that's yeah
oh one minute probably like
30 seconds left doom is coming i'm so
excited
wait where'd my cookie go it's right
here
you guys got your headphones yeah we're
set
it's one road is it on disney plus
what's up what's up what's up
is it yup all right hold on
let's do this everybody who's ready to
start this
i will show random clips of it um
i can't show the whole thing and i hope
most of you understand because
those of you in the alleycaster
copywriting we're going to be starting
it
at the count of go and you can watch
along with us or you can tune into
cosmic wonders
youtube channel let's see what time
we're at
all right guys we're gonna start episode
three in three
two one go
and it has begun
previously on one division
no no no
game time all right here we go is it
synced up yeah nice perfect
ah we had a thousand the intro
oh i forgot hold on
oh no i'm on the wrong screen
[Music]
oh here we go oh i forgot because i've
already seen it so
so real quick there's like this little
intro for one division
and this is what's being shown right now
it's like this little intro
of uh vision going on right now hey bye
gosh
it's like super brady bunch oh yeah
they've done a great job
super brady bunch right there getting
all their stuff for the
kids super brady bunch so that's just
the intro right there and it's just
the brady bunch one division intro all
right here we go
that's so cool
there we go it's the whole intro it's
really cool
yeah the whole thing's like so i killed
it because it's like 70s i believe
yeah seventy seven years seven days
just look at their outfit all right so
wanda is pregnant
and uh that's what this episode's about
never checked on my thumbnail
i did it was up okay
oh black tracks yeah
definitely pregnant no kidding
40 minutes
so they've been pregnant for about
a day and he said that one does four
months along
her vision is confused 12 hours
paul bettany looks like he literally
just came off a brady bunch set
vision is like freaking out
which isn't typical of vision that's
interesting
oh
they're trying to keep their pregnancy a
secret
uh i am the cosmic wonder for those
asking it is me
this is the face reveal
i love the house it literally looks so
laughs
[Laughter]
good pun life would be so much easier
with magic
magic so much freaking clean the house
just
this is not my sister we all live
together this is alicat
this is chris from cosmic culture i'm
cosmic wonder for those of you who have
never seen my face before
share your my snacks
with everybody
so uncontrolled magic
i'm thinking it's coming from her baby
that's a good point
yeah i think uh wiccan wiccan has just
made that happen
billy
little do they know they're going to
have twins
they're not gonna be called billy or
tommy either
hey thank you the jcke
wonder culture cat
bailey tommy hmm
friday afternoon in three days
[Laughter]
vision is like freaking out about this
nice
braxton hicks
let me give you guys a little another
little peek in here
whoops this is what kind of we're on
right now
just one to being pregnant
vision trying to read some books about
one of being pregnant
vision changing diapers and uh juan is
kind of making everything go crazy
abandon the kids abandon the kitchen
i love the stash yeah right
such a great mustache
my gosh
one is worried about everybody finding
out their secret
but vision's getting yeah it's kind of
weird too yeah this is getting real
weird
see vision it's not vision
this is not vision not the not the
original vision at least
oh just flash she just reset it she just
reset the reality
vision was on the verge of figuring
something out and wanda reset the
reality to where he didn't know anything
and when he came back he was super happy
it's gonna be part devil
[Laughter]
is flying off the ground
i love them
share the cookie dude i share my cookie
with you all
[Laughter]
i like how she calls them biz why does
water broke and it started raining
inside the house oh god commercial
oh these are awesome
i want one wait wait
another hydra easter egg
so hydra is gonna be i think actually a
big factor
i'm about to have to tweet something
[Laughter]
drying myself off tweeting something
we want you to offer the pretty later a
cookie cosmic winter
now he's going to go get the doctor
who's going to get the division
mission's running at like supersonic
speed to go get the doctor
before he leaves on vacation
oh yeah i forgot about this part
totally forgot about this part
somebody's knocking on the door and
she's trying to hide that she's pregnant
but she's like huge she's like she's
gonna pop any sessions
really huge oh and look who it is
it's foxy so foxy
one is like literally in labor and
trying to act like she's not she just
keeps screaming
so it's clear she doesn't have control
of her powers right here it's just
flashing all over the place
she's so rude the woman told her like
four times to not come in the kitchen
and then she goes in the kitchen anyways
oh my bad
uh
hey stu meat super appreciate that hey
that's a pretty cool little
[Laughter]
i think i need a there you go that might
be better
it's foxy it says gametalk it's foxy
there's the the stork oh came to life
did i mention his name when he donated
yeah i think so
he's just yeah yeah he says thanks to me
stork's running around the house right
now and she's trying to get her she's
trying to get rid of that but she can't
control it he can't
yeah joe she just resets everything
anytime vision gets close to figuring
something out she resets the reality
he just wants to join the party i think
it's mephisto
you think the stork is i think the
stork's involved somehow either him or
well you know it's like a minion or
something
the kids are about to be born so he if
there's somebody or his kids
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
she is straight up about to have these
kids
actually she cares
hey thanks prasad i appreciate that
hey what's up malik
malik said what's up cosmic culture
what's up alec how you doing
he fire you
i love how well they nailed the time
frame yeah i also love how she hasn't
figured out that she's pregnant yet like
and that there's a stork running around
her head yeah
i think the house is hilarious i wonder
if that's just part of like you know
the funny jokes or if that's part of
like juana's trance on everybody
here's the babies
how convenient for wanda and vision
[Laughter]
priorities
uh it's it's it's both malik he's gonna
have twins
or she's gonna have twins now
she's having kids and like everything's
like falling apart in the house
chandeliers are falling the fire is like
going off the lights are flickering
pictures are flying off the wall there's
a store
there's a store there's a store
too late baby time hey brian mackey
what's up man
how's it going bro
she's pushing just pushing and things
are getting crazier
it'd be cool for you this will be you
one day babies
i woke up and i had a sandwich and then
there was a baby oh
there's the baby there's baby number one
uh this episode is what is just over 30
minutes yeah
it's got 14 minutes left on it 32.
nope there's a doctor doctor's here road
on vision's back to get there buddy's
here
a big newborn
it's like he can't walk straight
vision's about to hold his baby for the
first time
looking fresh after giving birth yeah
right
here i'll show you guys this part no
vision's face is revealed
she said don't you want to meet your son
as you actually are
vision phased into a human
imagine you're seeing your dad for the
first time he's red
trust me for these babies it's not going
to be that weird true
baby
oh she's having another one
there's another baby coming
twin babies
20 fingers 20 toes
two baby boys two baby boys wiccan and
speed
mommy and billy and billy yeah yeah
girl power
he's a big baby
oh yeah
escape that's that's
small towns so hard to escape
and now vision is getting curious again
even the way he said it was like
obvious oh yeah oh this part's super
important
nosy neighbor agnes
another mention of ralph that we never
see
his neighbors acting super weird
they're very suspicious of uh monica
rambo
oh wait
here's the name drops that i tweeted
about
i'm a twin
she just mentioned quicksilver
she's singing
ultra oh he was killed by ultron wasn't
he
monica just remembered something she
shouldn't have
no home
dun dun
liar
about
uh-oh
oh wanda's gone real serious wanna get
pissed
nope sword necklace wanna notice the
necklace
accent is back brian
it's a it's a sword emblem it's not
upside down cross
who are you
she don't seem to know
a lot of weird stuff going on
you know what's cool about this is that
background scenery was just a painting
in the back
which is like true 70s yeah tv show
and they made it obvious enough oh she's
gone
gel dean's gone
she left honey
west view
oh and out
and she is kicked out of the reality
it's interesting that she's still
wearing the same clothes
from inside that's kind of proof that
something's real
yeah it's an interesting unless you it's
a different reality maybe
because she goes in every day she didn't
have a home and everything that's true
[Music]
what's interesting is sh sword almost
doesn't know who she is right here
like where are they like what's with all
this stuff
yeah and that's it leaves you waiting
for more
yep and that's it the rest is just
credits i've seen it all already so
dang there's a lot there at the end like
really like in the last
so much in the last five minutes there's
so much in the last five minutes
so much in the last five minutes yeah
there's i know
i i want like a post credit scene but i
know there's not gonna be one until like
the very last episode of the season
so i mean what do we think
uh you think i need to close this i
think i need to
let's take this three thumbs up three
three thumbs up
from ali that's insane so let's here
hold on i can kind of go over some of
the parts here there's this alley cat
official alice official
we all live together
so at the end there she gets kicked out
what is this
yeah i was trying to read the signs what
are all these symbols the ones on the
bottom they kind of remind me of like
almost military signs
eagles club is that what it says
it's really blurry there's an eye on the
right almost like the illuminati almost
like a vision
or the vision i don't know
uh nothing really legible it's super
blurry i can't
see it and if i zoomed in it wouldn't
even be
something it's where you make it
home is what you make it it's what you
make that's what the sign underneath
west view says
home home is what you make it it's
he sure says what or where home is where
you make it i think
home is i think it's where you make it
because that's a that's like a normal
saying
but i would have really preferred it to
be home as what do you make
because it would be like the reality
it definitely says where it's there's no
tea and it's too
it's too i'll just i'll show you guys
what we're talking about here
on this sign in west view we're trying
to figure out like what these things
are right here it says home is where you
make it right here
uh i wonder what the second or uh brown
sign means because it says like parking
you can fill up you can eat
but the second one yeah i don't know i
don't know what that symbol is this one
is
yeah uh this is alley cat
oh wait hold on there's not a cat
you can find her on twitch alicat
official at ellicott official
you can find chris cosmic culture on
youtube
on youtube and we all live here together
in our house and this is warren hi um
you can find him
on the cosmic wonder youtube channel you
might not have heard of it
maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe
huh yeah
well um what is everybody's thoughts
oh that's a very good point uh who just
said that andy pick that's a very good
point this is the real sign in the real
reality
not the one in the in wanda's reality so
this is probably all normal
but i was just wondering if these
symbols right here
underneath are of different organs i
wonder if she'll put them there that's
all but
but it doesn't look like they did
because you got like an eagle club and
stuff like that
um one of my biggest questions is is
wanda's body somewhere here
on earth and she's in some type of
machine no i think that's
she in a different reality no i think
that's her body in a different reality
so
and then everything else is fake around
her except for people who are
no i think the people are real i think
everyone's real
they're just kind of under a spell and
that's why they randomly are like whoa
i'm kind of coming back
yeah and then she said right back so is
she the one doing everything yeah what's
up jason marshall
um is she the one doing everything i
think
yes and no i think it's mephisto and her
i don't know who started it
but my thoughts are i want another
well we're gonna have to wait
dickie you said this explains everything
how does he look like that
i think the crane luke thornton that's
what you were saying i don't know why it
keeps
the festive probably blocking all your
messages but uh
yeah i think um
i think the crane is mephisto like i
really do you were saying that while the
show was going on yeah because like
because if they are his kids truly i
think he was like
checking in right like he was like
watching them being born
that's what i think was actually
happening gabby says daddy is mafesto i
don't not believe that
yeah it could be um personally i think
vision
is actually gonna end up being mephisto
that's what i think too
but i could see dottie being mephisto
we'll see we'll have to see
daddy's definitely evolve somehow with
that
daddy is definitely something um i think
all the people are real
and they're under either wanda's spells
or mephisto's
hexes i i think most of them being
controlled
and i think maybe agatha
i still don't know if she's good or bad
i mean she could end up being both she
could end up start off
she could end up being either because
she was so she was super questioning
what was going on with monica
and i think monica is definitely good
monica is definitely good right so
monica makes her lean towards bad bad
right yeah and she could end up changing
later on
yeah or she could be under the control
of mafesto somehow because if she is
who she is she is she's powerful yeah
and so and what a threw her out because
she
[Laughter]
um i don't think the kids are fake i
think the reality is fake
but i think the kids are gonna fist
those kids
um i really do
agnes mentions ralph again yes she does
yeah and you never see ralph ralph just
like
never ever so maybe ralph is gonna end
up being mephisto
i feel like we're all pretty sure it's
gonna end up being mephisto though right
there's no questions about that at this
point i don't i think it's mephisto and
grim reaper and hydra's got something in
there hey
did she take over this town is that why
everyone's scared of her
um you're talking about
uh and first of all thanks grayson the
khan um
thanks for that donation i are you
talking about
moniker and bow or are you talking about
wanda i
i think wanda definitely has this town
under some sort of fake reality spell
and that's why sometimes they think
things are going on and sometimes they
don't know
right um and that's why like sometimes
vision gets closer to finding out what's
happening too which i still don't think
vision is
real and alive um
so what were urban agnes talking about
yeah i don't urban agnes were the most
confusing characters in the whole show
yeah i i think it was probably agnes
really more talking to
herb um because i think herb is just
he's not a side character because he
definitely plays some good he plays a
good role but i think it was maybe agnes
coming up to him insane have you noticed
that this woman doesn't have a home and
he's probably like oh
oh yeah i did realize that this that
that they don't have a home
like yeah i i really did so
i don't think he's a major player like
agnes because i do believe agnes is out
of the darkness
uh thank you again grayson and what do
you i think one it could be the
antagonist here
i've been slowly moving away from the
classic hero yeah no i i definitely
think that too
um i think my thoughts on on wanda is a
lot of what's going on
whoever is doing this to her is also
trying to contain
wanda you know kevin feige specifically
went out of his way to say she's the
most powerful in the mcu
i think a lot of people realize that
during endgame and sword or whichever
agency
is trying to contain her in some sense i
do think that has something to play with
it somehow or another
yeah uh noah navarette it's really
interesting because i have a buddy named
philippine i've read who has a son named
noah navarette and i don't think that's
you but it is
um but i do think they're going to come
to the actual reality yes i do uh
waverity productions thanks for the
donation
v seems like his own entity outside of
want to spell uh kind of yeah
i'm so confused on vision because i do
think he's somewhat
i think he's going to have an influence
or mephisto will have an influence on
him
i don't know i don't know if he's alive
or if wanda has just created him in
in this thing rubber knob love the
privacy place hot chick in the middle
great angle
check her out at alleycat official on
twitch thank you
we all do actually live together so
so it wasn't that hard to perfectly
place her while we're on the topic of
the hot girl in the middle what were
your thoughts on
the setup for the show as far as like
you know it replicated the brady bunch
oh i love the brady bunch i think it's
a cool vibe that they're giving that
they don't really do
much anymore and they killed it with the
way that they
dressed the way that the house was even
set up it was all
super well done and weren't even
mentioned behind
herb was the the painted yeah it wasn't
like all actual backgrounds
and it was done until you could tell on
purpose oh right because
it wasn't like the 70s sitcoms and so
one is definitely creating these
oh hold on cam k thanks for the donation
if mephisto is involved
maybe he's trying to use one his powers
his bridge to get boris regular hey
that's a really good theory man
yeah he's using this to get the kid
because he's like yeah yeah
yeah i agree so he's in the hell
dimension maybe he could be using
wanda's powers as like a segway
and i think he wants the kids um
i think he wants i think he wants to
have kids
somehow and i think he needed somebody
strong enough to have those kids
who is a magical person and i think
that's wanda i think after watching her
you know through age of ultron to
avengers in-game where she almost killed
thanos
i think i think he decided that's
her and so if if if mephisto actually
wanted to take over
let's call it the main mcu realm right
um if if mephisto wanted to take over
then what better way to hat
than to have kids born into that realm
right and what better there's a purpose
what better parent
than to have to have your children
than to have probably the strongest
character in that realm
you know uh yes miss g ralph has to be
100
mephisto like it seems like uh
i i just don't i don't see how it's not
melts over on alicat's dream says who
are those people who found the lady at
the end is it shield and are they modern
day shield
what happened to shield it's sword
um which is a different branch of
shield they're the same they're like the
same thing that's just a different
branch so
so shield how it's supposed to be right
i don't know
what they're going to do in the in the
in the episodes so what shield is
supposed to be
is the like the earthbound people and
then sword
is the sentient world observation um
they're in charge basically like
extraterrestrial threats like cosmic
threats out of space threats
so i think shield might actually warp
into
sword in the mcu i think there's gonna
be no more shield then it's just gonna
be sword now
so they're just treat them as the new
shield essentially
yeah and then one more from ally cat's
dream it's uh two thug bill
how you doing man i'm not watching the
episode but do you think doctor strange
will make an appearance somewhere
down the line towards the end of the
season what was that
do you think doctor strange will end up
showing up in one division absolutely
do you think he's going to show up to
save wanda i think he's going to show up
and be like what the heck is going on
what is this
so hold real fast into madness let's uh
let's revisit that huh let's let's put
this here
and let's see what we got so you think
that the photo spinning
was uh oh machia mimaki i think all the
towns people are dead hence the grim
reaper being involved oh
and that's why the dude with afro saying
we're all we're all dead that's actually
oh really that's my vision's there
hole i think you might have just figured
it out i'm not even gonna lie
um i think you might have just figured
it all out
man infinity shades thank you for the
donation
adams was trying to hide the truth
because she was working with mephisto
yet in the trailer
she makes vision realize he's dead
and you know what going back to what you
said before
um and finishing this good point be
right back but going back to what
machia said maybe in the trailer when
she's like am i dead
no why because you are and that's like
am i dead because i'm in the dead
reality yeah yeah which is probably
controlled by the grim reaper and of
course which would be
mephisto at the same time she's not
gonna be dead
yeah so infinity shades i do think agnes
is bad i do think she's trying to keep
the truth hidden
from everybody um
yeah to screenshot that take a picture
of that
because that's uh going into the final
yeah
that's going to my video tomorrow
because i truly think that you might
have just
figured something out right there i i
really do think you figured out
something right now
um dang okay
all right thank you all for your input
so let's go let's go hold on people are
saying
let's check out this uh the picture
spinning
nice bob one nice what spot you just
choose oh when she was giving back so
where
okay not here yet right it was past this
is it spinning when she gives birth
somebody
something this is a sign well i know but
it's while she's actually
she's giving birth that's what she's
actually giving birth because because
when
when when she kind of starts to yell
everything yeah that's when she
first starts giving birth she'll play it
back a little bit just played there
yeah these things are spinning i think
it's right after this
it's not that one i know which one
they're talking about so do i but
uh it might be is it that one because
there's an all silver one
an all silver one
that might have been all of them there
might have been one more we missed chat
what are we looking at here
it's spinned while she was giving birth
you know we're thinking
i think we passed it i don't think
there's any more spinning ones
i i mean i don't know she gives birth
again oh there it is
no that's not that's the one i thought
it was so i don't know then
that's not like a picture
uh
i see everything's going crazy here
maybe it was the first one
hold on i gotta bring this down because
i can't uh
show all this or my video is gonna get
taken down
but let me look right here for it um
i'm not i'm not when the fireplace
explodes so that's before
[Music]
uh i mean the fireplace exploding is
obviously a sign to me of
mephisto i mean so where am i at
all right so she's gonna give birth
again i think they're going to kind of
go crazy again
oh yeah you can't escape the small towns
that mine is that's a huge line
yes
yeah andy picked that was like a super
sus conversation
with uh with agatha with agnes
we continue to call her happiness until
it's otherwise revealed that she's out
of the harkness
even though we have leaked photos
showing her in a witch costume just
gonna throw that out there
okay so going back to the thing spinning
hey grayson thanks for another donation
i feel marvelous misleading us to think
it's mephisto
huge change in tone and pace for them to
take how sure a way he's involved um
i'm pretty confident that it's mephisto
i've also heard from a few
uh insiders that i know that they've
heard
that it is him i i can't exactly what
it's just tendon oh herbert i'm not
exactly
sure
maybe herb is the grim reaper good point
luke thorson
yeah that's that's that's definitely a
possibility and it's agnes working with
oh wait wait is that it
yeah the first one go back on the back
wall here the brick wall
it's on the brick wall in the back
son of a it's so it wasn't that one yet
there's one more
when she's walking back i think it's the
same one though
no because it's on a brick wall nope
look at that look at that ten dollars
from
oh hey just because it's cool give me
next
what's that one scooby next thank you so
much for that i don't know what this
picture is i can't freeze frame oh whoa
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
dream reaper no
i can't stop it if it's any of them it's
that one though i i can't stop it
it looks like fire yeah yeah that one ew
they don't it's not slow enough to
really know for sure but it definitely
looks like something
easter egg dang i'm gonna have to really
go in this and freeze frame it guys
but we have a lot of work to do so thank
you alliecat
and thank you chris roster from cosmic
culture for joining me
i'm going to jump on a zoom clone out
with supes and brad lambert who works
directly with marvel robert downey jr a
bunch of really famous people
so that's what we're gonna do right now
thank you guys for joining me thanks
guys
have a good one okay let's
figure let's figure this out
let's figure out how to get on a call
with these dudes
let's get all my stuff so a lot
maybe you want to find that chris that
photo
all right we're jumping on zoom call
with some two cool peoples
let's figure out how to do this
yeah we're gonna have to like so
these kids also considered real humans
yeah
i definitely think they're real let's
get this going so
open i'm getting a zoom meeting
going with some peeps here
all right what do we got please wait me
and your host let you in soon
all right all right all right let's try
this
this is in i'm gonna have to change this
one second
hi welcome king
it's going great bro welcome
oh my goodness wild bro
dude oh my gosh i guess
i'd say we threw those name around for
sure yeah
yeah me and brad talked about it before
before it started
i love it and it was just like
damn they really i i dude out of the
you texted me you were like oh um you
got one right because i tweeted back at
you when you
yeah but dude i thought it was strange i
didn't think it was actually pietro
oh oh time out time out on that note
they have said the word strange
so many times in the first three
episodes
like not needed to be said but they've
said it
yep okay i don't think i'm muted anymore
sorry guys
um so before we get started i just want
to say this because i can't figure it
out somebody in my chat told me
that when one is giving birth and the
photos are spinning around
one of them it's it's of mephisto
yeah no way yeah i can't find it i've
literally like seen all of looking at
all these photos and all this stuff i
cannot find it
and i like i'm really i've like went
freeze for him and just kind of
i'm gonna have to like transfer it into
imovie or something and like watch it at
like point two five speed
yeah dude cause i ca i can't find i
don't know if you guys can that's why
i'm mentioning it
but um i found oh no okay never mind i
was gonna say i found one that kind of
looked like something but then i
just see it right here and it's not
bro like how genius is marvel to like
have stuff literally
kind of like the grim reaper easter egg
right
where we're gonna have to literally
watch this episode in point two five
speed
i know it's crazy
um yeah guys i see some of you guys
talking about a promo in the chat
there is no episode four promo as of
right now the promo's fake
if it's not coming from marvel then it's
not real yeah no
they're going to be so tight with this
too like
for sure so there there's a shot at
um 1721 1722
of of one of the the paintings
but it's so quick that to me it doesn't
make sense as to why they would show it
unless it was significant
yeah i i i can't find it
yeah it's that that's an interesting
theory if it is true but i agree
we're gonna have to take it into imovie
[Music]
okay yeah see i see one photo here i
don't know what
uh there's a really weird
abstract photo that's like on the
staircase
like behind the staircase i can't figure
out what it is
maybe it's just you know like art
i don't know if there's a frame where
like it's just
standing still dude and i'm i'm checking
on twitter right now
someone said that in wanda's um living
room
yeah there's six chairs and six candles
on the chandelier
again pushing out the sixth thing wow
yeah they're so good they're so good
dude i know they're so good what
what this is insane man marvel is just
so crazy
good good at what they do dude but we've
never seen it at this level
like the level the amount of easter eggs
and just like hidden details we
i don't think we've ever seen it at this
level yeah seriously that grim reaper
easter egg
that was like like a half a second
yeah right like i mean and it's so
funny that they they put them in there
for us like the people
that they know are gonna sit there and
like watch
you know what i mean it's it's cool that
they do that stuff right
because i mean i'm sure it's like super
cool for them but it's also
got to be partly for us right i mean 100
percent
the earrings had eight angles i don't
know about that
i don't know if that means anything i
should say oh monica's earrings
so i want to talk about the conversation
between herb and agnes
um yeah that was huge that was huge
yeah because oh okay so
i will say this and i'm sorry i'm
talking so much but this was a cool
theory
that somebody just threw out um
and i screenshot it so i know their name
and i'll mention in a video but
they said what if this like so-called
place that everybody's trapped in
what if everybody's actually dead
and they were saying that maybe maybe
that's what herb and agnes were gonna
say they're like
because she's because she's not dead
and if you tie in like the grim reaper
easter egg
perhaps maybe because vision is dead
right so that would also kind of explain
how he's there
i mean the guy just mentioned it so i
haven't like wrapped my head around it
yet but i think yeah
interesting theory yeah interesting
i don't know there's also been like
how can i wear this there's also been
moments where vision has creeped me out
but not in like a uh creepy like oh
you're weird but like in a creepy
he could be the devil kind of way
yeah see i i didn't get that from this
episode man like i really got convinced
that like
vision isn't mephisto because there's
obviously theories out there that vision
is mephisto
and that's why he wants wanda to have
his kids but
like in this episode like why would he
try to break wanda out of the mind
control
no what i'm saying is like clearly
vision's dead
like fat oh yeah yeah he's dead so what
i'm saying is like
if mephisto can jump from different
characters because nobody's
real or they're completely uh being
manipulated and taking over
warren i think they've just taken over
this small town
oh yeah so i think everyone in the town
can't control what's happening to them
or what they're
doing i think they're literally being
controlled and they're stuck
in their own bodies so i think vision
is what wanda wants him to be at times
but also
mephisto inheriting his body and being
him whenever it's convenient
the one creepy moment i had was when
wanda
had the first child and the way he
looked down at the child that wasn't as
a loving father
or someone who just had their first kid
it was creepy to me at least
so that there's something like we all
know mephisto wants the kids
so that would be a perfect moment for
him to just slip in there for a hot
second
oh yeah and you know it was just yeah
i don't know yeah oh
so much to like i will say marvel's
doing like an insanely good job
at keeping the mystery because i
personally thought
going into at least the first three
episode we'd figure out somewhat what's
going on
yeah but uh really i think
next week's gonna be insane i think yeah
for sure
and especially since since like they
they only let the review embargo for the
screeners
only two episode three because after
episode three it's probably gonna get
like
really well really and it's interesting
because i
i emailed my contact who sent me the
first three episodes
and i was like hey do i get the rest
he's like no i'm like come on i'm like
he's like yeah we're not we're not doing
that as of now um
okay so people in my chat have said 1723
pause and then 1332
i'm on 1332 i'm not seeing anything
yeah yeah that photo on the back i don't
think that's
the 1723 that's the one i was talking
about earlier
uh you have a machia thanks for the
donut and he i mean that's a really good
theory that
they could all be dead and that's what
herb was trying to say
you know monica is an outlier because
she's not dead
and also that this could be uh
interesting warranty
so i want to get your opinion on this
when when vision comes and
uh wanda's like you know don't you want
to see
your son 23 as your
real self he transforms but there's a
split
second where there is this red glow
around vision um
and that look that detail for me it
lasts a split second but
if i recall i've never seen a red aura
around vision so for me that's either
wanda changing him
or it's the latter which we've talked
about earlier
it's at it's at uh 1857ish
it's very quick his jacket his shirt
glows red is anyone else uncomfortable
with like the long stare that wanda has
at vision before she says that
like she just stares at him for like
three seconds and just smiles it's kind
of weird
that's what i'm saying that she's she
almost feels like
possessed as well like that in that
moment when you were talking about
uh how she was at the end where she's
like she had to run home
like that was like something that you
would see in the conjuring
where someone is completely possessed by
the devil
and just this is true i'm getting chills
talking about this this show is cracked
i think for sure dude no you know you
know it was the first thing i thought
about
i thought about that scene in um game of
thrones season seven
where we just know that daenerys is like
long gone daenerys is crazy
like i i got those vibes from that scene
of wanda at the end
and i love how just like in a pg show
they're just injecting so much horror
every episode i've seen so far
there's probably kids watching this like
expecting you know if i see one that's
longer like a happy
you know well if she's gonna be the
villain well i should say the villain a
villain
in multiverse of madness she's clearly
going to have to uh
well brad sues we talked about this last
time how like maybe at the end she just
like maybe doesn't necessarily villain
but just doesn't care anymore
yeah she's kind of heartless whatever
she wants zero empathy
no connection to anyone just because
clearly shield is involved in some way
here
and you know like you know the good guys
aren't lurking out for me the bad guy's
trying to get me
screw it i'm gonna do whatever i want
and anyone who gets in my way whoever
that may be
i'm gonna take out
so i i found something interesting
though that somebody mentioned
in my chat it's at
23 22. it's a really good
really good look at agnes pendant yep so
she was wearing it as a brooch before i
believe it's the same one
yep it is and now it's on a necklace so
it's clearly significant
yep and then it was a pin yeah this
looks like
the grim reapers uh what they call it
pyre
yeah um like the blade thing i think
that's what it's called
yeah the scythe scythe that's what it's
called um
it almost looks like that
like at the very very top of it and it
almost looks like two
kids on the side yep right am i like
freaking out here
it's kind of like you're right it's like
the grim reaper next to
two kids hey joe thanks for the donation
i love you too thank you very much
i'm but i don't know that's what i see
um somebody said it looks like
mephisto's head
yo so and someone else conor connor
pointed out in my chat that um
to like remember in the trailer that
scene in the halloween episode
where agnes tells vision that he's dead
right
right so it could just go in line with
the theory that everyone in this town is
dead well right and that's what that
person was
what was telling me as well they were
you know saying like
everyone could be dead except for rwanda
yeah and that's kind of and that's kind
of why
monica is like the outlier because
they're like she's alive
why is she here what are you gonna say
brad
well i i mean vision is dead you know
so that's that's what's weird about this
whole thing is you know if we're gonna
go the whole theory
of everybody is dead in the town i think
the instances where
like in the first episode where uh mr
hart's wife
was like crying while she was laughing
hysterically at the fact that he was
choking to death
like that leads me to believe like these
are just people
stuck in their own bodies right and
obviously agnes isn't a part of that
theory
there's also the shot and i believe the
next episode where the woman's hanging
up the clothes
and she's crying profusely right right
oh right right
it's to me i just feel like uh
that is more of the prevailing theory in
regards to
the town um and honestly it would be
even more messed up if every like wanda
and mephisto and agnes are taking over
an entire town
obviously wanda doesn't know that but
she's being manipulated to doing that
i i would agree with that i think yeah
that would be like so messed up and you
know agnes is just
pouring gas on the on the fire man she
she's there to get what they want which
is i think we're all assuming
the twins
yeah and that's gonna i guess like
that's the the main thing that's super
interesting moving forward
is that now that the twins are here all
right what's the game plan
like what's going to go down because
this whole episode was a
it's always been about the twins like
it's since the beginning of the show
right so it's been for the children
right
so not that now that the kids are
actually here what's the game plan
what does agnes want or mephisto or
whoever is behind the scenes
so i just kind of like came up with
something on top of my head based off of
uh
someone in my chat that i'll have to go
back and find who said it
um but they said like what if mephisto
is using wanda as kind of a gateway into
like the earth realm because he sits in
the hell dimension
and we don't really know what like what
boundaries or limits like
mcu mephisto will have but that got me
thinking
like what like if it is mephisto behind
everything which i wholeheartedly
believe oh one thousand percent i've
done a bunch of videos on it by now
and um so why would mephisto want
kids well if he wanted to take over
that realm what better way to do it than
to have his kids
and if he had to have kids who better
to have kids with or put kids inside of
right
then what is most likely the strongest
character in
on earth right i mean it to me that just
makes a lot of sense
and i'm looking at the the sign at the
end
i don't know if they showed this but it
says welcome to west view
and in quotes it says home it's where
you make it
thanks thanks where uh thanks for that
don't know appreciate it
i was looking at that too because i
actually thought it said home is
what you make it and i thought that was
clever but then i realized it's where no
it's where
i i looked at it um
it was pointed out that that is the real
sign though
in like the real reality because it's
like right outside a sword i don't know
if that means anything or not
oh either way it's ironic you know no
absolutely
because that's exactly what wanda's
doing
oh my god in this scene where where
vision
is um kind of like spazzing out at
towards the beginning of the episode
dude he looks directly at the camera
like directly at this at the audience
yeah that's awesome
and like you could see like on his face
he just looks so uncomfortable
like he's being controlled by something
well in in you know maybe back to to
brad's point
um maybe he doesn't have so much control
and maybe he wants it yeah so
um monica's earrings are six-sided
oh yeah but
so i i'm confused about
how monica's there and i'm also confused
like if she works for shield already it
wouldn't make sense that she does
because of the whole captain marvel
connection
yeah but man i i'm confused as how she's
there if you notice like
when she gets kicked out shield they're
like all surrounding her and they have
their guns out and everything but
that could just be because they don't
know it's her that got kicked out
but and she has the sword logo i guess
so i guess she does work for sword
already
so and that's that's something we talked
about earlier and just to confirm
supes you and i were talking about this
earlier was it the fbi was it sword
i looked at that end credit scene i
paused the sword logo
is on the side of the vehicles uh one of
the doors
opens up and it confirms that so i do
believe they've set up base outside of
this town
uh and on that note warren we were
talking about i mentioned this earlier
that you know when the appearance
changes right
i didn't see that necklace on her last
episode
no she didn't have it last episode oh
yeah so as the
uh sword agent who came up from the
sewer system
he had the sword logo on him right right
i think it's possible that the sword
necklace was placed on her
unbeknownst to her yeah like as as a
as a tip to wanda because that's when
she lost it right
is when she saw that symbol again which
was on the helicopter
which was on the beekeeper right so that
symbol has been everywhere
and placed in plain sight to really kind
of set the tone that every time you see
this you're going to be uneasy every
time you see this you're going to be
scared
so when she saw it on her yeah because
even
eva monica kind of looked down and was
like what the hell is this you know
right she didn't really know yeah and uh
right here in my chat uh cr
1138 thanks for dinner says what's with
all the beehive references like in the
credits
and the beekeeper and episode two aren't
aim called the beekeepers
is aim called the beekeepers yeah are
they
yeah yeah they're called the beekeepers
of the marvel universe because their
hazmat suits resemble
right she stuck joe
ex ed thanks for donato she snuck in
like the beekeeper and he was sent to
check on her
that was a noise at the beginning of
episode two that's why she's so out of
place hmm
taylor what are you thinking your mind
is like i see the wheels turning
i'm trying to figure out how the hell
aim would even work into this like i've
heard theories that like
um sword is aim like disguised
as like if that makes sense like aim is
disguised as a sword
but i don't know i feel the same dream i
totally feel the same and thanks for the
nation
um grayson vachon thinks that the next
episode is going to be from swords
perspective
and it says in the trailers it's clear
that monica is a sword agent and
obviously yeah but i was actually kind
of thinking that too because remember
we've already seen the helicopter
yeah but in a in uh in like a tv spot or
trailer whichever
one it was we see like that had the
helicopter flying by and then we see
that like
red magic orb which i think we can all
agree is probably what like sucks the
helicopter in right
yeah we didn't see that happen so maybe
the next
episode or two or you know who knows is
from a different perspective
because they are clearly watching her on
somehow on like a tv however that works
so maybe they'll show us a little bit of
that
and i said this earlier because we were
talking about how that wasn't shown this
time
it could either be uh disney's in
marvel's way
of misdirection like they always do with
trailers and clips to
you know show something one way but it'd
be different in the film
yeah exactly so i think it's either that
and this is what it looks like or as
wanda
and this all pocket reality begins to
kind of self-destruct
and get more powerful i think maybe that
that dome grows and becomes more vicious
and powerful and that's where we see the
red
vicious cycle and maybe that's when
mephisto shows up right that's that red
color we were talking about
so maybe when mephisto actually shows
his ugly face
this is what happens and and the dome is
in full power
at that point yeah maybe
i like that um can we talk about
how um was
senior scratchy and the first one and
the stork in this one
i think that's though right yeah cam
kay's point
i i i fully believe ralph is either the
grim reaper
or mephisto maybe the grim reaper
because of the pendant that i can now
see in agatha's chest
but um so the stork is there you know
as she's going into labor right if it is
mephisto's kids i'm thinking like he's
there to
to watch and she tries to get rid of him
but she can't right and she controls
everything right i mean she can re-rate
the reality yet she can't get rid of
this
the stork and it has to be magic
stronger than hers
obviously right which yes
um cam k i think mephisto hasn't learned
how to properly turn to human yet
hence that's why he is turning into
senior scratchy and the crane
maybe it's it's kind of hard because we
don't know the
we don't know the the boundaries and
limits
yeah that marvel will give
to so just like in the infinity gauntlet
comic um
thanos didn't have to close his fist to
do anything
and in infinity war he did
and that's why doctor strange in that
one scene was like don't let him close
his fist to his cloak
yeah and then the rooster brothers
explained like the gauntlet is just so
strong
that we had to put you know limitations
on it to where you had to close your
fist to use it
and you could really only use it once or
it would kill you whereas in the comics
thanos is using that thing like crazy
and it's doing nothing to him
so yeah go ahead no i was just gonna say
there
there's probably some limitations to
mephisto
so the this tweet i just saw the next
episode
could be like we said earlier from
sword's perspective but most importantly
monica's perspective
so how she got into the alternate
reality
which we've seen clips of her like
nearly touching it
with woo behind her and then maybe
that's when we see
how wanda actually eats her out of the
pocket reality
yeah and uh grayson russian thanks for
done i just said it could be
misdirection but trailer clearly shows
monica getting four splash across the
field
in 70s attire so
yeah because we didn't see that right
we just kind of saw the ending of that
so yeah we very well could get that
indian perspective
or that sorry any perspective the the
perspective from
her
i think that probably yeah we'll see
and then that's where we see you know
the shots where we've seen from the
trailer
of kind of wanda like literally throwing
her out of the reality
right like we could see that from
monica's perspective
yeah and also um well i guess
[Music]
i was gonna say remember in one tv spot
we saw like wanda um
fixing the wall in the children's
yeah yeah i think we'll pro i think
that's probably something different
i i i first thought it might have been
monica and then i actually thought it
was the kids who did something and she
was just repairing it
right maybe like wiccan wicken's powers
got out of control or something like
that and she just had to repair it
so i think i think we'll figure that out
later
hmm interesting hey macchia thank you so
much
all the commercial follow events one is
like yeah like for real with the hydra
yeah i still want to know why the
the neighbor i can never remember his
name
thank you i want to know why he was
cutting through a wall i feel like
that's like
something important well someone said
mention the comments was like he cut
through
the fourth wall but uh
i don't think there was like a fourth
wall break during that part maybe
someone looked like directly at the
camera or something like that i
i don't know but yeah that's certainly
something to
that was just a weird scene i like yeah
i just think it's odd behavior
the fact that herb's not fully in
control
and it's just like a a broken machine
you know yeah it reminded me of the the
dinner scene man
yeah the wife was crying and she
couldn't really exactly crazy cool and
creepy
that's a great one that would be crazy
thanks for dono
and um i just want to point out if this
actress that's playing monica
which we obviously know is going to be
in captain marvel too yeah she's gonna
be playing spectrum
who's like a main player in the mc
moving forward how great was her
performance in this episode
she's very very well she really showed i
feel like she really showed her like her
acting chops
she's great just bouncing off of wanda
yeah
and when it got serious she was really
good at like yeah oh i said
i said this and she's like oh my gosh i
like to touch on that i
love how
eerie it got when wanda was like when
when she dropped ultron and she was like
what
and it was like no i want you to leave
and it's just like
like dang
it maybe that's how we see that scene is
they asked monica
sword asked monica how did you get out
right and she's like well
this happened and that's when we see it
from her perspective
that would be great yeah dude knock out
now i'm thinking okay what if
since monica has that information of how
to like kind of trigger wanda
what if i guess darcy's role in the show
with somebody they're certainly
misdirected
would be to recreate something
that triggers juana's memory whether
it's creating
another version of ultron because we
know that
wanda has ties to that and she has
trauma towards ultron well you're sorry
you're talking about monica's care
monica
i'm talking about now that monica knows
how to trigger wanda and break her out
of
you know the mind control right what if
now that she's working with sword
oh that's her job gotcha yeah
she gives him that intel and that would
be darcy's role because i'm still
thinking like how does darcy play a role
in all of this
dude i don't know if like monica wants
to
trigger wanda though like because she
seems really uncomfortable whenever
wanda started like
yeah like oh why'd you say that like and
then she started like backing off like
she
shouldn't say it and stuff like i i feel
like that was a a moment
where she lapsed and snapped out of her
being controlled
and uh truth just spit out of her mouth
yeah
because like you said she she kind of
felt like wait what did i say
what did i do wrong you know like she
regretted it
yeah yeah like well more so that she
didn't realize she had said it
and then she was trying to backtrack
because she
what did i say what did i do
this show is amazing yeah i was gonna
say they're doing an incredible job at
like
really making you like into it like oh
dude yeah man
and it's like every single episode sorry
nonstop
so david donaldson thanks for the donor
did agatha remind anybody else of miss
gulch from the wizard of oz when she was
on that bike so i actually think
i noticed a wizard of oz yellow brick
road picture
in maybe the kitchen
and that's another you know hint that
it's not like you know real
um
[Music]
trying to figure out where it was i
think it was like when tano maybe was in
the kitchen
and it's very tiny dude another thing
too
again since wanda literally had an
entire nine month
pregnancy and like
in the span of like 20 minutes yeah
do you guys think next episode could
could potentially be the halloween
episode i do
yeah if it's not next if it's not
actually it's the week after
oh dude could you imagine non-stop
30-minute episodes
just like straight boom action action
action
yeah wild
i want to see what 250 million dollars
looks like in those final three episodes
right geez
that's what they spent on this oh yeah
oh yeah
that's ridiculous 150 for falcon and
winter soldier
dang okay wait yeah so at 17
13 uh
i don't know there's a there's a picture
in the background next to monica
would i which i thought was like a
yellow brick road wizard of os thing but
i don't know if it is now
could be
which again would just be a kind of like
hey guys it's not really real you know
she's gonna
tap her shoes and wake up at one point
i could see it right yeah i i don't know
it just kind of
reminded me of it when i first saw it
and now that this person mentioned that
i was like
maybe the other thing too i've noticed
and you know correct me if i'm wrong but
generally when wanda uses her abilities
she has the red aura right going and she
also
has the red eyes right so i feel
like from wanda's perspective
she's not aesthetically
using her powers right she doesn't want
to come off threatening
she wants to be normal so that's why
when she's using her powers
we haven't have we seen the red aura at
all
on her end as far as using the powers
like when she's
you know uh sweeping the floor or
cleaning or anything at all like when
when she got pissed like i expected to
see the eyes change but they didn't but
then again we see the
the the clips from the trailers and the
commercials where we see the iconic
red aura around her the balls of energy
her eyes red
so that leads me to believe that there's
some uh intentional things being done in
that regard
dean that would be crazy no strings in a
commercial that would be pretty cool
yeah for sure so cause when when things
are moving
like there's not even a red aura around
it it's just like they're just it's just
it's just happening yeah or like or like
when like
like that scene where vision kind of
glitches out again
like that or even we didn't even see her
move in that one
it was just like yeah yeah it was
instantaneous
so switching topics really quick because
another hydra easter egg
do we think that they play or do we
think this is kind of just
i mean why mention it if it's not going
to be something
um dude i think the i think they're just
tying it all back to her trauma
yeah their backs could be that right you
know hydra experimented on
her stark yeah struck her yeah
the missile story you know of it landing
right now
yeah maybe that's just what it is
because if it's
hydra aim shield grim reaper
that's a lot of stuff that's a lot of
stuff happening there hmm
i feel like they're just throwing like
little
hints and stuff in but like it's not
even like they're just like nods to
things you know what i mean just to like
throw us off
it's very frustrating also when she was
singing in sakovian
with her accent that was with the accent
he's shot man i wanted because everyone
was i'd like tweeted something out
because everybody like one day was
talking about like where the heck's her
accent i'm like you hear it again don't
worry
and it's such a cool scene and still
like man
my heart dropped like the first time
where she was like i was a twin and it's
just kind of like oh
and then it's like she mentions beat
throw and you're like oof and
it's like killed by ultra and you're
like oh
i'm like dang i'm like because you know
there were like rumors so
long for so long in like past few months
it's like oh ultron's coming back
and i'm just kind of like i don't know i
don't know if it makes sense to bring
him back
but that drop that name drop was
dude but i mean i feel like we can't
rule that out moving forward you can't
now no of course not
no and especially with the multiverse
i can't really rule anything out now
and and the thing is that we know at
some point
you know it's likely that we're gonna
get a quick silver cameo to some extent
yeah i i think so i
you know and that that that actually
might deter from the whole
dead thing because wouldn't her brother
be there
yeah everyone was dead yeah
it could be a placement to push her over
the edge
right not specific yeah maybe they're
holding him back for that
he's ralph ha maybe right
hmm well i have no um
i don't really have i would say like i'm
99
sure that that crane was mephisto
oh for sure yeah with the red smoke well
that was probably
right every time she tried to like get
rid of him it was like red smoke
and she couldn't get rid of him in a
reality that she apparently controls
right i mean
so maybe she doesn't control it because
that's because brad we talked about that
last time i think
um yeah i haven't decided
i haven't figured out i should say if
it's if it's wanda who has created this
thing
or it's mephisto either way i think it's
irrelevant because i think they both
have some
control on it but represent it right but
maybe mrs toe is more maybe it's his
right because clearly she could not get
rid of that
that stork yeah she she's being
manipulated 100 percent
so i i think mephisto started this i
think he's controlling her up to a point
i think he's letting her drive the car
but still in control
right that makes sense um cam k thanks
for the donor made it
actually kind of a rather important
thought what happened to the beekeeper
because wanda just said like
no and then he was like yeah
die or get kicked out like monica that's
interesting what happens then
i don't know that's a that's a tough one
yeah we don't know
like just glitches out well because like
we talked last time i like the idea
that there's like the bubble around the
town and like he went underground in the
sewer to get into the bubble mm-hmm
yeah did he just get pushed out
or or it didn't happen at all or that
yeah you know
so then what does that look like on the
other side then right exactly
you're a sword a shield agent sword
agent gosh that's going to be
and you just sent somebody in next thing
you know they're right next to you again
like what
didn't you leave
yo someone said in my chat that the
stork was
pulling monica's skirt and that could
allude to
like the stork wanting to remove her
from the whole situation
oh i like that i would agree with that
oh i like that a lot
[Music]
this is kind of random but the reality
stone
like just popped into my head and i feel
like it would make a lot of sense
just like like if she's in like control
like has power with the reality stone
because that would like explain why
everything's red and why like you can
bring
people back from the dead yeah red red
red red
alternate reality well and i guess if
there's
i mean maybe that's what mephisto's
using
maybe or somebody right because how do
you
i mean maybe maybe one is using it
somehow she clearly has some connection
to
at least the mind stone but you would
think that
they're all connected somewhat
interesting yeah we're and we're getting
that flashback scene of the mind stone
so we know that at some capacity they're
gonna show shed some light on the
infinity stones
that's what i think the the hexagon
shapes mean because in the intro of
episode two the like cartoony intro it
starts with like six dots and then it
turns into a hexagon
so i like i don't know i personally
think that it's like the infinity stones
that's a good point
like that's what you think like the six
means in all of this mm-hmm
yeah that's sexy yeah it's a really good
point
that's a very good point i think it's
either that or like 666
obviously like the level one yes but i
feel like that's like almost too dark
for it
i'll have to look at disney including
the show you know what i mean
yeah but i also never thought they'd be
making
a show like this yeah
i love you this is right up disney's
alley let's just say marvel
what's up brad i love how the stork went
up against the wall
right along the painting yeah i thought
that was so clever it's clever yeah
you know it's funny you
you watch shows and like the more shows
you watch of something like typically
the more you catch on to
but i feel like i'm watching lost and
i'm just like
like what's going like i have somewhat
of an idea but then the next episode of
marvel's gonna like completely shatter
that idea
and i'm gonna be like i have no idea
what's happening yeah um
we're gonna come out with like theory
videos this entire week just like
dude
do you guys think that um that mural in
the baby's room of the stork holding the
baby
do you think that had any significance
so like mephisto
controlling the kids or wanting the kids
watching the kids yeah or or simply
because kind of kind of you know how
like
and explaining like a store story to
kids like the stork is almost like
apparent not really but it could just
mean that you know mephisto is the
parent right
delivering the kids like bringing the
kids that's
that's how right there the historic
delivers
the kids yeah and that's what he wants
right so i
it's clever so clever i think that i
think that would be it
but in the painting on the wall there's
only one kid in there so what if like
professor just wanted the one kid but
then she ended up with two
that's a great question wow
yeah that's super intentional but but
also
but also originally wanda thought she
was having one kid
yeah so i believe wasn't she the one
that
made the painting come out right so she
like snapped her finger so to speak
and the painting came on the wall so if
she's in belief that she's only having
one kid which at the time
that's what she thought you know i think
that's really interesting
wait did one make the story come out
no she made the painting on the wall oh
yeah right gotcha gotcha
but what if like she actually she did
get pregnant and it's like hers and
visions baby but then mephisto was like
imma just add a little spice in there
and one of them's evil oh yikes
can you imagine is this literally a
horror movie
well and we've seen hints of that right
and like
yeah so i mean someone's
i think i think it's going to take a
dark turn i really do i'm ready for it
i'm so ready for that because i mean you
think
that doctor strange was supposed to be i
don't know with sam raimi now doing it
supposed to be a horror film yeah it's
going to be a horror movie right right
it's supposed to be i don't think it's
gonna be as bad
as if it was uh scott davison directing
oh for sure he like
fully yeah he wanted the four that's why
he's raised there right now but
i mean frick i i think it's gonna take
like a pretty dark turn maybe the last
three episodes
because it'll lead into that movie so i
mean jeez
wow
oh jeez i love it
i love it so dude it is it's so nice to
have conte again
right dude that marble theme
at the beginning oh my god guess me
retirement
so so epic
dude i almost i almost watched it with
like the audio in the background the
whole time
my chat saved me did you show it on your
screen
no i show parts every now and then i'll
just like
pop the screen up real fast just to give
a little something but yeah i'm not
trying to
i'm not trying to get my channel taken
down yeah definitely not
brad you said that with a very like yeah
i i know these guys don't do that
yeah don't do that no i'm not trying to
i'm not trying to get that done um
leila miller aka butterfly helped
everyone remember who they were
in house of m story wondering why so
many butterflies referenced in this
episode as well that's a very good point
true yeah and the baby's room well
this too i like that but remember an age
of ultron
the the significance of the butterfly
of evolution right remember the drawing
that that could be an interesting tie
back to
what happened in age of ultron with that
drawing of how they figured out that
ultron was going to put his
consciousness or whatever
into that new body
also on that scene
the first time i watched it and this
time again i bel
it's clear wanda didn't do that
which she didn't do the butterflies like
make them come out of the i don't know
what that's called
um the chandelier or not chandelier but
like the
baby thing yeah yeah yeah um
but i think it might have been wiccan
inside of her who did that
that's what i think too yeah yeah it was
like that's great
yeah a little little and because there
were some things that like she didn't do
then and i think some of the the things
like the crane were
mephisto but i do think it was like
wicked inside who was maybe doing
something
would be awesome i i think so and
now i was gonna say it may even could
have been wiccan that uh
was causing like chandelier to fall and
stuff like that but no i think that was
one oh
but on that topic excuse me
did we notice how wanda
really didn't have control of her powers
like her coats were changing
granted she was in labor but
um it seemed to me like she really
didn't have a handle on
that's like how i felt i think it was
the first episode when she was like
trying to make dinner and stuff and she
like
like the wanda that we know could just
like snap her fingers and she could have
like a full course meal like ready to go
right but she like acted like she was
struggling really hard like i don't
her powers just don't seem there yeah
not in control yeah that goes back to
what brad said
and and even about you know the mephisto
being the one who actually did do you
can smile
what's that someone in my chat said at
2 23 vision
has like a wicked smile after the doctor
says
no escape oh without oh remember that
line
that's crazy that was a crazy line you
know small yeah yeah that was huge
so at what was the mark sorry they said
i
at 20 23 20. oh 20 23
i said 223
they said after the line no escape
small towns
and if this is like a town that just got
like
i guess taken over by wanda's like
alternate reality like how i just want
to know
i i can't grasp that concept like i want
to know how it happened when it happened
like how everybody was affected like
it just seemed so out there and that's
the thing that something
big went down in order for all of this
to be created and we just don't know how
it went down
yeah we don't know
where this is picking up from
really did you guys see um that paul
bettany
revealed that there was almost an
avengers in the game post credit scene
where wanda yeah like uh one of the
corpse drawers
we have nothing like that to like give
us any type of lead
which i do think they will show us right
i think oh for sure flashbacks
you can't just give us all this he'd be
like wait how did that happen not tell
us
i do love this feeling of wonderment
though
i do like that we kind of like don't
really know what's going on
and it's fun to theorize so
especially with a show like this this
show is like
perfect for it it's like insanely
perfect for it
woof julie how's it going yeah i think
this episode was fit
fabulous as well
and the thing is that when it comes to
the movies like we could all have our
theories for like the movies but we'll
watch the movie
and our theories will get answered or
not right right
for here it's like every episode we have
a theory and then it just
gets completely shattered and then we
come up with new theories and it gets
completely shattered
new theories
hmm
oh man
it's certainly
it's pretty crazy i just realized she
had a tear
come out of her eye when they were
talking about her brother
yeah and that's really heartbreaking
it's just odd that
yeah yeah i've always thought about that
going into this show like if she were to
create the perfect life
why wouldn't pietro be in that
right exactly which leads me to believe
that it's not a perfect life it's maybe
not even her reality
have you guys heard the theory that like
all of this is taking place like
as she's destroying the mindstorm
no but i kind of like that
right like she just wanted like a normal
life with vision and so like as she's
destroying it like she's in like this
head space of like
the perfect reality for her in him which
i think is really sweet
but it is really sweet my only poetic
yeah it is which i truly enjoy and the
only
rebuttal to that i would have is that
it's already gone
question mark stones were destroyed
and i feel like i feel like i feel like
kevin's already said this takes place
after end game as well yeah but when you
have a universe like
marvel yeah the stones can come back
and what if there's a brother said
something
like they weren't just
someone said someone said that
at 20 2150 the baby on the right has a
mark on his forehead in the same exact
spot as vision
21.50 yeah no
no way he does oh
yo no way interesting
dude is that wicked or speed that might
be wicking
dude i would hate to be speed
like my brother got all these super
awesome powers and i can run fast
hold up i think the other bb has
yeah i don't know if it's
just the one yeah because you can't see
the other baby
for like a split second it's like at
21.47
this is another one of those imovie
framed frame things
uh his head's turned it's really hard to
see
monarch butterflies represent mk ultra
which is a program in the military used
using microcontrol
interesting thanks for that at 2140
what's interesting uh monica begins to
blink rapidly where she's kind of
snapping out
of this and that's when she says that
comment
about pietro shortly after
and that's that's even even uh
wanda snaps out of her trance
to an extent yeah okay so it's at sorry
yeah almost the 22 mark yeah right there
right there
20 21 56 monica blinks
rapidly where she has this realization
and she turns and says
the line about pietro
and then wanda does the same thing
shortly after yeah
so it is almost like
the veil there's like a veil over rwanda
too
going back to what you said i i do i do
think maybe it is mephisto that is doing
this
this is just what like honestly we have
just for the last half hour or so try to
go through this with a fine tooth comb
and by
by wednesday we'll have stuff that we
completely missed which is yeah
yeah this this um it's funny because you
know like
we do breakdown videos and like the
breakdown videos have turned into well
it could be like one of ten things like
so i'm gonna do this one
um
dang but it's super again i'm still
like almost giddy at how much we don't
know because i just think it's so
yeah they're doing an cool job with this
and just think about like
our minds are kind of blown with like
these little things that are happening
wait till it like really gets going
that's the thing man that it hasn't even
started it really hasn't
it's the setup really yeah like
the show could have started from right
here because like this is where the
story
this is where the story starts with the
kids being born
yeah dang
so now i like one of the questions i
i've been asking since even like before
the first episode showed
do the kids make it or
do they get this dissolved with the
reality or mephisto takes them back or
this is something that i've gone back
and forth with
so many times right because in the in
the comics
they disappear but then they're
reincarnated into other children born by
other parents
and then everybody realizes what it is
and then they
unite with wanda so is it something like
that
right i don't think that make it either
i i don't think they make it i think
that's what sets wanda off
yeah same she loses her kids and vision
yeah she loses everything
thanks night monkey and what up
i do think mephisto is going to be the
next big bad though kim k thanks for the
donation
i i think for sure um
he and he did to your point there cam he
did
help with spider-man i shouldn't say
helped
he also spider-man's identity in the
comics you know
erasing everybody um
yeah erasing his identity in the in the
comics yeah after civil war
hey dreams and one more day thanks so
much for watching
yo ralph looks good in the dark thoughts
ralph looks good in the dark
so sorry timeout dream thank you
at 1848 you can see other baby's head
okay
1848 oh yeah because she's like holding
it
no no mark on the head but he said
something about
mark on the chest you can see mark on
the chest the mark could just be real
life
oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
there's like a red dot there hmm
they're they're they were just born guys
too yeah they were just and that's
that was kind of my that was kind of my
like thing about like that mark in my
head i was like babies you know
you touch them and they read marcus
memphis though
right confirmed
al pacino as mephisto that would be cool
i'd watch it where
where wanda feels empty like her
her looks like when she's talking
division or somebody it's like she's not
not there like there's no soul there's
just
it's it's very odd i feel like it's
because she knows that it's not real you
know
yeah no that's a very she's just trying
to play along yeah
and that same same with the scene i
mentioned earlier today where she had
that brief moment of
of fear panic and sadness where she's
like i can't do this
i can't do this and that's maybe why
because she knows she can't do this
because
this isn't real but she's still going
through it well if you go through
what she's been through and all of a
sudden you're finding yourself
was given what you want i mean probably
just go with it
right yeah i mean you lost so much
hmm i can't wait to see what mephisto
looks like
honestly i'm scared yeah
i i hope he is i will cry okay this is
totally off topic have you guys seen
insidious
yes oh my god the devil that's what i
imagine
yeah like and it freaks me out i don't
think they'll take it that far
do you all think it'll take your time i
think it'll be a mix between like
that creature and like hello i think
though
i almost think they'll make him like a
slick
very slick person like lucifer right
yeah like
loose i would i would be down for that
you know what i mean like very slick
very
charming like does it reveal he's
mephisto
yeah yeah okay and that's ralph
i think so i think mephisto's ralph or
the grim reaper at this point since she
had
since i think the pennant very i should
say very clearly but from what i can
tell it looks like the grim reaper and
two kids
yeah dude that's vision realizes what's
going on
then time rewinds thank you for that
donut beast mode yeah
um wanda does that
you know her perfect reality she has to
protect
which is why she sends monica out of the
reality
and says she doesn't send monica out
like this is my party you're not allowed
in dude to be honest i'm more scared of
wanda than i am with my fist though
oh facts yeah well we talked about just
one
what did we talk about last time like
rob uncontrolled power
right that's scary
like that's stuff that like you don't
mess with because like for someone who
like knows what they're doing
you almost know their potential but for
someone who just kind of like doesn't
have control you have no idea
like how strong somebody is at that
point right you have no idea
her yeah oh in my chat said that's good
that um someone in my chat said that
agnes
only delayed vision intentionally so
like that he wouldn't walk in on wanda
during that scene that's smart
wait say that again wait during what
scene like agnes
not stopped vision from walking into the
house
intentionally intentionally so like that
vision didn't walk in
wow wanda was having that moment with
monica
but also don't you think vision or
either of the other two would have heard
monica get thrown through a wall and out
of the reality oh yeah you would think
yeah vision was right outside they were
all right outside that's what i'm saying
well he was very
um like almost like he didn't believe it
right
uh thank you for that dean excuse me
yeah i did see that
and i think that's something we actually
aren't going to see him be the wizard
character i don't even know how it went
down like we don't even know how that
went down bro
i think we will see it though next week
yeah for sure
at some point for sure whether it's next
week or the week after i i think we're
definitely gonna see it for sure
someone said if you turn on the captions
at 20 30
you can see what agnes is saying to herb
when she whispers them
wait you mean you guys don't normally
watch it with captions
i don't know i don't i can't because
i'll just read the captions
that's the point no because i'm trying
to watch it yeah it
takes away from me it's called
multitasking
i think i think women are better at
multitasking
i agree i agree
okay at what
20 30. he said oh i'm way better
wait what agnes says the herb you mean
yeah well that's not at 20 30.
oh here we go she's like whispering tim
yeah
did you see her go inside she went right
in
and her tummy was uh they're just
talking about wanda
oh well maybe not they might be talking
about
monica going inside
yeah they said and her tummy was but
they never saw wanda because wanda was
never outside
i think that's just agatha knowing that
wanda's pregnant so she's spreading
rumors
but how did she know because she which
yeah she knows she knows what's up with
everything well i
i i go back and forth whether she's good
or bad but
i do think she's working for mephisto in
which case she knows everything yeah
she's back which case she knows
everything
it's just kind of weird because she's
good in the comic she helps train her
but that's what i feel like it's like
they're trying to make her seem like
she's going to be a bad person
but it's just marvel like misleading us
like they usually do
you know because i want to see her be
here
these people you know that aerial shot
of monaco
no black widow they did the black oh
tomorrow
i'm alive but i'm dead oh internet
no that's terrible oh my god
that's so funny
he had to do it oh
wait hold on okay starting from here it
says
wait i just had it so they are
whispering what is she doing
in there i don't know howdy howdy
did you see her go inside she went right
in and her tummy was
did geraldine dot dot dot
and gomorrah dang oh gosh
if one of three geraldine out doesn't
want to then have to know that there's
an outside to the reality of course
yeah yeah i think she's i think she's
caught on to that fact but
maybe like us she doesn't really know
whose reality it is if she made it or
somebody else made it but she knows she
can somewhat control it
i that's what i'm saying i don't think
she cares she's like i'm in my dream
world and i'm gonna keep it that way and
nobody's gonna mess with it like the
beekeeper
like monica get out yep i just
i like i i'm so curious as to how this
was even like formed because they
literally have like football stadium
lights
cast onto like this this right shield
or whatever it's almost like they like
intentionally
set it up like i don't know it just
feels
strange i don't like it and how was a
helicopter
so readily available the second that
jail dean got thrown out
i think i think they've set up camp like
once they
realized they were ready yeah they're
watching they just they just set up base
operations around this oh so you felt
like it happened and then they were like
okay well this is what we're gonna do
now
yeah until they figure out like what's
what's happening
they set up the base of operations right
after the first episode
they showed like they're clearly
watching like a television somehow
they're
they can see everything happening so
they're like oh someone got thrown out
like
let's go get her um cam k
thanks for don't know could i get to be
more of a hostage than a partner to
mephisto
and maybe has her own intentions with
wanda
maybe it's totally possible i'm just
to that point again i bring up i don't
know how this all
started until you just said like
you know something happened then
everybody set up shop around it it's
like
did she have a mental episode and
explode and the reality was created
you know what is she in a lab and like
you know some theories like are they
using that uh
uh that scroll who are the other people
i know
are they using the cree technology that
they kind of used on captain marvel
right and they're kind of like in her
brain and stuff like that like so many
theories and it's just
dang i don't know
oh man oh my gosh soup's not funny
i can't with the birdie memes they're
killing me
paul paul bettany's did you see that one
that he posted today
where they opened the box and bernie's
inside in the second episode of one
division
[Laughter]
they're killing me with those memes man
guys uh love you to death what an
episode i have an early call in the
morning and i
gotta bounce all good i have a 12 hour
drive
in the morning drive safe oh man
absolutely uh tails pleasure meeting you
yeah you too soups as always
epic you guys do the best yeah you guys
are awesome next week
see you guys bye
well everyone dang oh sorry my camera
i don't even know my camera still on it
might have lost power oh no i'm still
here
dang that's uh there's a lot so
i i saw this uh episode
monday yeah i saw this episode monday
uh disney sent it to me a little bit
before
and i had my thoughts i wrote them down
now i have a lot more to go through i'm
gonna do breakdown
so i'm gonna dive right into
everything i possibly can thank you all
to
thank you so much to everybody showed up
tonight i love these watch parties i
love talking with you guys
um it's pretty cool because i don't put
myself out there on
my channel that much because i firmly
know that
it's about content and not me so i try
to kind of
stay back from that um dean al pacino's
with
that's hilarious uh the breakdown's
gonna be coming
i'll probably put it out at like
eight or nine am my time so that's gonna
be
[Music]
five six hours from now um
thank you cat tiger yeah uh it's
actually a whole thing so it goes from
here
to over here the whole black panther
poster
um i was gonna give it away because i
thought it was really cool but then oh
my battery died i was gonna give the
black panther
thing away but of course chadwick died
now i'm gonna hold on to it forever
sorry camera died yeah monvi
it's it's gonna get pretty crazy
pretty pretty crazy so i'm gonna go
get started on my breakdown guys i think
everybody
who showed up for this we're gonna be
doing the same next week
i'm gonna be out of town so uh the
background's gonna look different but
we're doing it next week vijay draws
hello welcome for the first time
do you uh dream some thank you for thank
you for the dino do you think the person
watching this like a show
sees the rewinds i don't know
wow that's a really good question hey
max yes i do remember you haley
how's it going um
yes i think they do see the rewinds
because i don't think she's influencing
the outside reality
i think she's only influencing the
reality that she's in which means they
would see that
um red afro thunder
it's been good stay hydrated yes
absolutely i hope your day's been
because well who was the girl not sure
who you were talking about if you're
talking about the girl who was on my
stream that is ally cat you can find her
on twitch
a-l-l-i-k-a-t she's my roommate
and she's awesome um
yes i did see that so vic do it i did
see that that she was
glowing and yeah and mephisto could do
that too because you know the whole red
thing so
so yeah genie x yeah they really did
i hope you enjoy the rest of your night
too as well haley um
uh dang max that's like you have to wait
till the next one
um or tomorrow but hey enjoy it it's
super cool um
all right guys i'm gonna start my
breakdown thank you so much to everybody
who stopped by thank you so much to
everybody who donated
and participated in the chat i love you
all i will see you in the next live
stream a week
from